[CAMERA SHUTTER]
SPEAKER 1: Yeah.
Get up there with Rachel.
SPEAKER 2: taking pictures.
You want to get in?
SPEAKER 1: You going to
throw down on me now?
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 3: Yeah, Sally.
She wants one of you
and Brian with her.
SPEAKER 4: Yeah.
SPEAKER 3: And then we
do one with you and her.
[INTERPOSING VOICES]
SPEAKER 5: Graduates,
you're looking great.
Please continue to make
your way down to gate 18.
As soon as you pass
through security,
get that cap and gown on.
Please keep moving your
way down to gate 18.
Make sure you look great
before you enter the field.
The field is open.
FITZ AND THE TANTRUMS
(SINGING): Am I
the only living soul around?
Need to believe you
could hold me down,
'cause I'm in need of
something good right now.
We could be screaming
till the sun comes out.
And when we wake we'd
be the only sound.
Get off my knees and
say a prayer to James--
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 5: Congratulations,
graduating class of 2018,
[INAUDIBLE] members
of the Bear Band.
Thank you.
[CHEERS]
Thank you, [INAUDIBLE].
At this time, I'm pleased to--
THE CHAINSMOKERS (SINGING): I
want something just like this.
Oh, I want something
just like this.
[CHEERS]
[FIREWORKS]
THE CHAINSMOKERS (SINGING):
Something just like this.
Somebody who.
[FIREWORKS]
[CHEERS]
THE CHAINSMOKERS (SINGING):
Something just like this.
Somebody who.
I want something just like this.
[CHEERS]
[FIREWORKS]